yeah did you what was this speaking of
dumb japanese laws
you can be arrested in japan if you uh
mod uh games like save files
yeah that sounds all right can you
actually yeah
so a guy a guy in a skyrim community are
sweating right now
a guy uh a guy in uh nagano i think
nagano was uh
arrested and fined 65 000 pounds
about about a hundred k in dollars um
for selling breath of the wild save
files that were modded
seriously yeah no check and apparently
like i've read about it apparently one
of the main reasons why this law was
passed was uh
because guess which company pushed for
it nintendo
yeah of course they did
but obviously they tried obviously that
[ __ ] just america's like la mao no
they're not passing that law in america
yeah
yeah because you have the right to do
whatever you want with the products you
buy
yeah yeah but yeah nintendo somehow
managed to very push forward
to be fair like i think the selling part
was the problem right like
if you just like put it on but it's also
it's also illegal to even
modder switch oh yeah yeah but i think
it was like extra bad for you
because he sold it isn't it isn't it
technically illegal
everywhere to mod a switch or no no no
so in
the us it's counted as you bought
a product and you're allowed to do
whatever you want with that product okay
you can you can
do whatever you want so what's the
illegal part then buying the games
getting the games apparently
so i i think the way they managed to
pass the law is that like it's still
like an ongoing
thing like a service you don't actually
own the game right you own a copy of the
game
and by changing it you're like ruining
or if you buy a nintendo product
nintendo owns you
it's insane there is no escape you know
like it's uh
didn't apple try i don't know if it's
illegal and again can you check it if
it's illegal to jailbreak your phone
i can't i'm pretty sure it's not a i
think it is
i think it's in every country i don't
know is is it or does it just break
warranty
i don't know i thought i thought it just
broke warranty in the uk i can't
remember though
it definitely at least breaks porn yeah
i know that
yeah every everyone knows that but uh
generally that's what the [ __ ] you want
with the stuff you own i've never heard
of anyone getting
arrested for jailbreaking well to me i
mean just the idea of a like a [ __ ]
a raid going on like into some guy's
house like
just get down stop drop the legend of
zelda copies
put them on the floor and
you know in japan right the thing is in
japan right boys rock up with hazmat
when they when they arrest people in
japan they don't arrest you with two
people
they send like 20 [ __ ] police
officers in yeah when they're arrested
they send the boys down
man they go they got the whole squad
coming overall it's breaking your
iphone's form
yeah yeah yeah it's absolutely
guaranteed i think it differs between
the country but in terms of like apple
it's like you don't get yourself no no
yeah so you can
and they're not gonna [ __ ] sue you
for doing it yeah yeah so it's just your
warranty's gone yeah
that's yeah that's but i mean that's
understanding well most products do that
like hey if you [ __ ] change this
thing
we're not gonna fix it if you break the
seal that says this
breaking the seal breaks the warranty
then generally you know that breaks the
warranty right
yeah but then i feel you know you also
have to understand that japan
is you know falling a little bit short
on most
common sense laws like uh fair use for
example yeah i mean
i think failures just isn't the thing
here just seeing
all these videos of like nintendo fans
playing with nintendo to like change
their mind and then like after living
here i'm like dude
it's it's it's not going to happen
that's not how it rolls
yeah it's like us pleading with nintendo
is not going to [ __ ] do anything
unless you start unless you're in the
start-up
let's get them to change the law unless
unless you are unless you are
uh fully 100 japanese and in that
boardroom meeting with them it isn't
going to matter
yes unless you are miami it's not going
to change